[Music]
yesterday Hillary Clinton became the
first female in American history to be
chosen as a major political party's
presidential nominee this is huge news a
lot of people are thrilled I like that
guy check it out right there look at him
[Applause]
sorry I take an era you're a big Hillary
supporter then yeah Hillary whoa okay
that's great all right okay all right
free hugs I don't free hugs yeah I just
thought that this is such a momentous
step the struggle for gender equality in
America that women deserve free hugs who
wants a free hug ladies
Hey Ya sir can I just say I don't think
I think that's really appropriate not
appropriate
you don't think gender equality in
America is appropriate shame on you
congratulations okay no I'm just saying
that you you just randomly hugging my
female audience members doesn't doesn't
feel you what's the problem Conan you
don't think women deserve hugs at 200
years gender-based oppression as mighty
backwards of you you deserves that hug
okay it's just obvious to me that you're
just using I'm sorry no he's using this
Hillary thing as a way to cop a feel
with women it's kind of pathetic sir
[Music]
sir are you smelling your hair right now
no no the only thing I smell is the dawn
of a new era now okay just listen stop
it stop hugging those women okay
not just women Conan where my birdie
bros at condolence
[Music]
[Applause]
you